oui
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est sale ici oh la la
zone c pas possible sans mais partout ça
colle aux plus anciens voilà des oies
qui marche un canard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est vrai un brin de toilette tout
fera pas demain à tous oh là là mais ça
n'avance pas et bien sûr les oies
s'énerve qu'elle embouteillages
heureusement ou à toi tout règlent la
circulation
il se transforme en feu rouge stop feux
rouges feu vert feu rouge feu vert feu
rouge feu vert feu rouge feu vert bravo
à tous et tous voila le résultat
[Applaudissements]
un peu plus tard à table avec toute la
famille doit tentons soit tu dois
beaucoup trop haut au résultat tout
marche pas droit
[Musique]
pour toutes on soit au dans ton état tu
ferais mieux de laisser ta voiture tu
sais et attention tu as quoi c'est là
que doit tout à tous mais les fous mais
c'est dangereux on ne doit pas en
conduisant à tous à tout appel les
petits voient tout à son secours
[Musique]
les petits watts où s'alignent le long
de la route de se transforme en barrière
de sécurité
ouf sauvé à 80 ans doivent avoir
quelques ennuis
[Musique]
ouais
aïe aïe aïe tonton soit s'est arrêté
sans mettre ses feux de détresse
heureusement les petits gars tout se
transforme en fait d'être f va bien
et vous vos papiers ah mais non mais
c'est pas possible vos papiers
attendez je vais vous expliquer je ne
suis pas d'ici je viens de l'espace je
passe mon temps à me prélasser
j'adore danser et m'amuser
mais quand je vois des oies en danger je
suis partout je vole dans tous les sens
pour les sauver
[Musique]
quant à toi ton soit il vaut mieux te
faire accompagner
au revoir à tous à tous et merci
[Musique]
et